eu chamo sandra correia sou empresária e
empreendedora social e agora está em 44
anos mas sobretudo jovem como vocês
porque eu acho que o que conta é o nosso
espírito
o que me traz aqui hoje é o cheque o que
eu chamo um novo começo para portugal em
newburgh infoportugal eu acho que vocês
são o futuro desses países a viagem eu
não acho que tenha certeza vocês são a
nova geração e são vocês que vão fazer
de portugal um novo país e levar
portugal ao mundo
eu acredito em vocês querem viajar
comigo agora vamos lá então esta sou eu
ea minha cork é minha família o meu cão
d'água português três anos é que chama
cork
podem perguntar onde ela está pois bem
eu estou aqui ela ficou na escola porque
ela também tem que aprender a ser uma
lei não é portanto agora que está na
escola e mais rock já fará parte da
minha vida outra vez a minha história
começa aqui eu sou terceira geração de
uma empresa familiar na área da cortiça
a estar vocês vêem foi plantada pelo meu
vôo em 1980 hisaishi e tem a se quer
dizer antónio correia são as iniciais do
meu avô tem 10 quer dizer que 2010 foi o
último ano em que nós tiramos cortiça
desta árvore quando nós tiramos cortiça
da árvore nós apontamos último ante o
último dígito cada ano porque porque nós
só podemos tirar a cortiça dessa mesma
árvore de 99 anj
portanto assim e aqui começa a minha
história e aqui que eu comecei no anti e
vim para outro pois ou seja eu trabalho
na indústria da cortiça mais de 20 anos
é vocês conhecem muito bem esta matéria
prima que é portuguesa e o que é que
resolve fazer
em 2000 numa época de crise que nós
tivemos na área do champanhe resolve com
a cortiça há mais ninguém em casa com o
ocidente
criar moda e criei a telcordia a pelcor
é marca portuguesa das flores moda em
papel de cortiça porque eu não queria
ser igual aos outros
eu sempre quis ser diferente porque eu
mexi de frente
eu não achei diferente o nash diferente
não não é minha maneira de ser é que os
5 meu coração ea minha intuição e amy
quer que o kiss kiss pegar na cortiça e
transformá la em algo inovador
vocês não se lembram se calhar alguns
lembram dos videojogos do espectro nós
tínhamos quando eu tinha 15 anos
hoje vocês têm e depois três chances daí
tenha um juiz ou seja antigamente havia
um videojogo nós ligamos uma turbina o
peti branco e hoje temos a playstation
antigamente havia uma mancha de cortiça
e hoje nós temos até o corte no fundo
foi isso que eu ea minha equipa
desenvolvê-los e fizemos e o apontador
não está a funcionar por qualquer razão
e vamos andar para frente vamos andar
para trás e prodist improvisa se não há
problema
ah eu queria mostrar o que é que nós
nestes últimos anos ok então é que vocês
o que tá aí também em papel pode
autorizar a cortiça como um produto o
style e de moda hoje
atualmente só se olharem para as imagens
do nosso cumbuco da colecção deste verão
tem curtir sua cor de rosa vigan com
alças em bambu tam em mauá em cor
natural e também misturada com outras
cores possíveis olham e dizem estar
cortiça isso não é cortiça está em
portugal itp o código então este pastor
no vocês vim aqui desde aquelas pranchas
de cortiça até os dias de hoje
já passaram 15 anos
nestes 15 anos atualmente pelo corte
está presente em mais de 20 países a
nível do mundo é abrigos em novembro
passado em nova york no soho a nossa
primeira loja afora
vamos agora para xangai no fim deste mês
a briga pelo coren xangai
vamos abrir uma nova loja em lisboa e
como estão dizer se o limite nem sequer
é o céu é que o que nós quisermos
importante tudo aquilo que nós podemos
fazer nós fazemos tudo isso que me em
copiar o core que me trouxe trouxe o
contacto com outros empreendedores
trouxe maior conhecimento do parlamento
estado americano do presidente obama
quem 2003 me convidou para representar
portugal juntamente com estes 27
empreendedores de todo o mundo precisa
que vem onde aprendemos sobre o business
innovation and entrepreneurship mas
porque eu passei três semanas com gente
louca como eu e com vocês nós todos
somos loucos pessoas de frente ainda bem
que se somos euros houve passar um dia
trocar e com uma das minhas colegas e
sentir o que quero é ser muçulmana o que
era ser passar o dia com um lenço na
cabeça na rua eu criei a troca de
culturas por nós na europa temos uma
cultura e os países da ásia tem outra
cultura e esta troca de culturas foi
muito importantes para perceber que
afinal somos todos iguais não há
diferenças as culturas são diferentes
mas a essência está no nosso coração
nós somos todos seres humanos e vimos
todos o mesmo local
tive aqui nos estados unidos nestas três
semanas a oportunidade de fazer o check
in no texas fundo bank é juntar à comida
para as crianças que têm necessidade e
em 2011
ganhei o prêmio de melhor em
empreendedora da europa pela comunidade
europeia entre 2011 e 2016 já ganhei
prêmios que já nem têm em conta o tempo
e agora em miami como a melhor entre r
95 mil
mas o que eu quero dizer se eu chegar
aqui nós sonhamos mas nós podemos
concretizar os nossos sonhos e aqui o
que eu vos quero deixar aqui é que nada
é impossível tudo que vocês quiserem
criar na vossa vida você se podem vocês
todos os dias podem querer fazer melhor
vocês todos os dias podem mudar o
percurso da vossa vida
o que eu tenho aprendido com pessoas
como vocês
ao longo destes anos porque a pelcor é
apenas uma parte da minha vida minha
outra parte e ajudar jovens
empreendedores com shows negócio já
fazer entre um golo fácil entrem para
que os possam concretizar os seus sonhos
e ir mais longe
então o que eu aprendi com vocês e que o
que as pessoas aprendem comigo e com
nada nesta vida é impossível tudo é
possível
eu tenho um sonho que era criar uma mala
da pink elephant da pink e officers uma
mala pink e aqui eu posso está em é pink
em 2003 em anaheim na califórnia com o
mal a pelcor que nós fizemos para ela em
concerto
se eu contar como é que eu cheguei aqui
gostaria que o dia inteiro a contar
histórias e anedotas
mas é só pra vocês perceberem tudo que
vocês querem fazer vocês podem fazer
não há um limite só assisti confiar em
vocês se vocês mudarem as vossas crenças
o mundo está em mudança tenham muita
atenção as vossas crianças aqui vocês
acreditam não tenham medo
substituo medo pelo amor façam tudo com
amor e os vossos sonhos serão tornadas
realidade